he'd been president of the united arab
emirates since 2004 but sheikh khalifa
bin zayed al-nahyan was rarely seen in
public
his role became mostly ceremonial after
he suffered a stroke 10 years into his
presidency
the country has begun 40 days of
mourning
flags will fly at half staff and
ministries will close for three days
may the nation's beloved deceased leader
be covered by god's mercy and may he be
admitted into the white heavens may god
grant us patience in serenity
with his gradual retreat from public
life his brother abu dhabi's crown
prince mohammed bin zayed became the de
facto leader managing day-to-day affairs
but sheikh khalifa was widely credited
with helping modernize a uae
he oversaw economic reforms and backed
the purchase of english premier league
soccer club manchester city
sheikh khalifa also served as a ruler of
abu dhabi the oil rich capital of the
country's seven emirates
the world's tallest tower in dubai is
named the burj khalifa in honor of the
late ruler now leaders across the arab
world have sent their condolences
according to the uae's constitution the
federal council which groups the rulers
of the seven emirates must meet within
30 days to elect a new president sheikh
khalifa bin zayed al-nahyan was 73.